hello everyone imagine if you were just
you know chilling enjoying your day
wherever you feel comfortable for
example in a bar in a library in a park
and someone walks up to you and asks you
if you would like to see a game between
Tigran Petrosian and vasily smyslov
played in the 1959 candidates tournament
your first reaction would be probably no
I don't think I would like to see that
that's probably a really long game like
120 moves that ended in a draw but if
you're one of those people that would
say that you would miss out on a pretty
amazing game as it's not long and it's
not and it doesn't end in a draw but it
might well have ended in a draw if it
wasn't for for a lot of brilliant play
so this is one of the games I decided to
show between Tigran Petrosian and vasily
smyslov and Smith Wolff has the white
pieces he opens with Knight to f3
we have b5 so starting off with a reti
opening c4 this is the Reta gambit and D
captures on c4 we have III Knight to f6
Bishop captures on c4 grabbing it back
at the pawn d 6 we have castles c5 and
d4 by d4 patrols and transposes into the
Queens gambit accepted we have a 6 Queen
to e2 this is the ejection system b5
Bishop to b3 and Bishop to b7 now we
have Knight to c3 and a Knight B to d7
so this is a Smith of zone variation of
the audience system how to how to
approach it with black rook to d1 we
have Bishop to d6 and now II for some
captures on d4 Knight captures on d4 and
queen to b8 here Smith lock already set
up a nice battery here attacking that h2
pawn
we have Knight back to f3 in defending
the pawn and now before and here
Petrosyan has a la not a lot but he does
have a couple of options here he could
play something like Knight to a4 which
does seem like the safest move although
if you play Knight to a4
you're giving up the
for pawn but excepting d4 pawn without
castling first could be could be
somewhat dangerous but there is another
option here for example there are some
tactics that you have to calculate for
example rook captures on d6 and after
Queen captures now we have this if I
move but after Knight captures and
Knight captures you would get B captures
and c3b kappa sorry bishop to a4 check
first and after the King moves now B
captures on c3 black would play
something like rook to d8 and now after
Knight to c4 attacking the Queen also
you have to be careful not to leave the
Queen on the dark diagonal as a3 is
coming
but even after Queen to c7 and I move
like Bishop to e3 King to g8 and
although this King is somewhat awkwardly
placed completely blocking this rook on
h8 from entering the game it is a better
position for black and it's it's
questionable if weif could use the
bishop repair and his pieces which are
not ideally placed to somewhat hinder
blacks development and take advantage of
this probably not as Petrosyan decided
not to go for this so after before he
decided to play another interesting move
he played Knight to d5 and this isn't a
piece sacrifice as he he gets the piece
back very soon
this missile played eek after Sun d5 we
have 85 now attacking the bishop and the
night so Knight captures on e5 Knight
captures on e5 and now castling of
course you don't want to capture this
night as well as then f4 pins the bishop
and like doesn't really achieve anything
here so instead of capturing sorry
instead of capturing first castles and
now Knight back to f3 as now the knight
really was attacked on e5 and also the
night now protects the h2 pawn again we
have rook to e8 attacking petrol since
Queen Queen to d3 and now a five with
the idea of giving some additional
protection to this before pawn and also
a four might be an idea in the future so
Bishop to G
five Petrosyan develops a piece also now
a four can be met with Bishop to c2 and
after rook is developed to c1 this
bishop can even go to b1 we have Knight
to g4 and here is again a very exciting
moment in the game
Smith's love is now attacking the h 2
upon 3 times with the knight to the
bishop and the Queen and the best move
for petrosyan is playing Bishop captures
on d5 grabbing the d5 pawn but leaving
the H 2 pawn so after Bishop captures
King to f1 and now comes Bishop to a6
pinning the Queen against the King but
now you have to block this Bishop to c4
and after Bishop captures Queen captures
nice to e5 attacking the Queen and the
night if you move the Queen as missile
will gladly capture on f3 so Knight
captures Queen captures and here you
have a position where Petrosyan is Smith
so is still up one point that petrosyan
decided to sacrifice by playing Knight
to d5 and also his position is somewhat
better as this Bishop on h2 is nicely
nicely locking the King on f1 there's
already and Ice Queen on on e5 and a
rock on e8 this rook is ready to jump
into the game wherever it pleases so it
would be a better position for black but
Petrosyan decided not to play this as
against Smith slope this would be easily
easily losing so instead after this
Knight to g4 he played g3 defending the
h2 pawn but this is actually even worse
and here's miss la will really show how
you can how you can play against the
former world champion as missile being a
former world champion himself when he
plays a move like g3 and he tries to
keep everything in order on the board
but now Smith will show you as of this
moment after Petrosyan played g3 it's
like Miss love is explaining to you how
how to play chess I mean it's like he's
explaining to a six-year-old how to play
chess it's also very natural and so
logical that it's it's just beautiful
here he plays a Bishop to c5 attacking
the f2 point twice now
so you have to defend this but it's not
that easy to defend it you can't really
block with the bishop because III Square
is covered by the knight by the rook and
by the bishop you don't want to go rook
rook to f1 if you go rook to f1 then
Bishop three six is an idea pinning the
Queen against the rook so here he has to
play rook to d2 now comes another piece
attacking the f2 square Queen to a7 now
three pieces are attacking two pieces in
the Queen are attacking you have to
square and now we don't really have a
choice here Bishop d3 is still out of
the question as now four pieces are
guarding the e3 square so he has to play
rook to f1 and if you had this position
against Petrosyan I'm sure you would all
very gladly play Bishop to e6 and you
know enjoy pinning that Queen to rook
and winning the exchange but Smith slow
again very elegantly he doesn't he
doesn't rush this position he he really
I'm sure he was really taking his time
here and enjoying Petrosyan suffering
here he didn't go for better 286 instead
he played h6 because now you have to
first decide what to do with the bishop
again we said III is out of the question
if you play Bishop to h4 you get g5
losing a piece so only move you have is
Bishop to a4 which which pushes the
bishop to a less active square and also
by playing h6 you create some breathing
room for your own King on h7 before
going into any skirmishes so first
improving the position and only then
does miss love play Bishop to a6
now pinning the Queen against the rook
here petrosyan moves the Queen Queen to
a5 and of course Bishop captures and f1
was played but although Bishop captures
on f1 is a move you really want to play
you know grabbing the exchange you you
have to take a couple of things into
consideration here for example but rosin
can capture the bishop on f1 he can
decide to capture the knight on g4 but
there is also one line that missile had
to calculate before he captured the rook
on f1 sorry and that is Bishop to see to
creating this Knight battery here going
for the h7 Square and you had to see
that if this was played that okay if you
put g6 then
we'll capture on g4 no harm done but
that you can actually play Bishop to c4
and that Queen to h7 doesn't really give
you anything after Queen to h7 King f8
Queen to h8 King ez 7 there is really no
way to continue checking the black king
and after Queen captures on g7 now comes
Bishop captures on f2 and here comes
Smith love's counter-attack King H 1 and
now rook to g8 and the Queen has nowhere
to go this diagonal is completely
covered g6 is covered g5 is covered so
only square for the queen is Queen to h7
and now Bishop to e3 is sufficient for
black to win this as you do have to
exchange here probably Queen to a5 now
white could even offer a second rook
here with the idea that if Bishop
captures rook this Knight can come to e5
and maybe continue the attack but Smith
law wouldn't have to go into any more
risks he could simply capture the bishop
and after Queen captures not like Queen
e3 and now it's all over you either have
to exchange Queens and then you lose the
game as white or you can try some more
checks and after King f6 Queen d6 check
King to g7 there are no more checks and
although the King did go for a nice walk
here he's back safely on g7 and white
can simply resign here so after this
Bishop captures an f1 Petrosyan decided
to play Queen captures on g4 grabbing
the knight also now inning the the g7
pawn threatening Bishop captures on h6
against missile had to take some things
into consideration and he decided that
this wasn't dangerous
he played Bishop to c4 he has to allow
this Bishop captures on h6 but Bishop to
c4 he really enjoys this move as if if
white ever captures on c4 he will fix
his own pawn structure the bishop is
nicely protecting the pawn on d5 and
also he's threatening to capture the
white bishop on b3 messing up White's
pawn structure
so first Petrosyan played Bishop
captures on each 6 we have g6 here
blocking checkmate on g7 and now Bishop
captures on c4 as he
decided it was a lesser evil than to
allow Smith's love to capture his own
bishop on b3 and also he found he found
not not not a tactic but a sea of
tactics here D captures on c4 and now he
plays rook to d7 and this is the the the
real critical moment of the game as here
you can see that although being down the
exchange he's on the attack and he does
have some pressure here the bishop is
very dangerous here queen is very
dangerous and g4 the rookies on b7 df7
point the knight is ready to jump into
the game so a lot of options for Smith's
love here
he could go Queen b6 you can go Queen b8
he could go Queen to a6 and of course he
could capture on f2 would check so let's
see what what petrosian's idea here was
if Smith still played Bishop characters
on f2 would check after King to g2 your
queen is still attacked you have to play
Queen to c5 to protect the bishop but
now comes Queen to f4 attacking the f7
pawn a threatening Queen captures and
then checkmate so you'd have to hear
you'd have to either play Queen to f5
blocking this after which Peterson will
capture the Queen and then capture the
bishop leaving him with a better endgame
or you would have to play something like
f5 but then you you're completely lost
after rook to g7 check you can't go to a
fate otherwise you're gonna lose the
Queen after Queen to c7 I rock the c7
but after king - king to h8 then comes
rook captures on g4 and black is black
is lost here whatever black plays white
has a very elegant move for example Rob
g8 and now comes Bishop to f8 and it's
all over with da with the idea if you
captured the rook of course you lose the
Queen on c5 if you play rook captures
Bishop then you get Queen to h5
checkmate and lastly if you play Queen
captures on f8 you get Queen to h4 check
the king has nowhere to go only move is
to block with the Queen and then comes
Queen captures on h6 and this is
checkmate
so after this rook to d7 move capturing
would be a terrible blunder so what are
what are some other options for example
we said Queen to b6
a viable option so let's try Queen b6
Queen b6 actually falls through captures
on b7 not with the idea that black is
lost here but with the idea that the
black will no longer be able to win here
what is the threatening rook to g7 again
and you have to you have to stop this if
you play rook to a7 to stop this then
simply rook captures Queen captures and
Queen captures on g6 so we'd have to
play King captures on f7 but then comes
Queen to d7 check rook to e7 blocking
and now Queen to d5 checking the King
also attacking the rook on a8 and after
rook to a6 blocking this rook to e6 you
don't want to go to the bank back rank
as then Queen captures will come with
chick so after rook to e6 now you play
Knight g5 check King moves Knight
captures Queen captures and now you
don't want to be hasty and grab that
rook and it
if you grab it then comes Queen e1 check
followed by Queen captures on f2 the the
real idea here how to draw with white is
actually Queen to d7 check and now white
will always be able to check the black
King White's idea is that he wants to
force the Queen out of the out of the
e-file so Queen e1 check doesn't come
with the threat of capturing gun honey
an f2 so Queen b7 check King b7 now 24
check back again 26 27 check again and
all the other moves will also result in
a draw so lastly after up to d7 we said
capturing is out of the question
Queen b6 it doesn't work what about
Queen to b8 you do have to play
something with the Queen if Queen to b8
again rook captures on b7 Angie sorry on
f7 King captures and now comes Queen
captures on c4 with check King moves
Queen captures and see if I would check
Queen d6 blocking and now Bishop checks
on g5 King 7 and now Queen to b5 check
Queen blocks and now comes Knight to e5
check for king the king and the Queen
but must capture rook captures Queen
captures and here you you're still up
the exchange as black but we
so wiping being very safe behind his
bones and black king being wide open
there is no way to win this game with
black so lastly we return to this
position it wasn't just you know
violently played that Bishop captures on
c4 and opened up the D file for his rook
played rook to d7 and you can see what
sea of variations missile had to
calculate before finding the right idea
here's missile played Queen to a6 and
Queen to a6 is a very devious way of
stopping rook captures on f7 if fro
captures on f7 now then after keen
captures again Queen d7 Czech rookie 7
now Queen d5 check King to g8
Knight to e5 now comes covering the d7
and the f 7s were threatening Queen to
g8 checkmate but now this was missiles
idea rook captures knight on e5 Queen
captures and Bishop back to e7 Bishop
pins the bishop on e7 threatening Queen
captures with checkmate but now comes
Queen to d6 and white White's attack is
stopped black is simply up a whole rook
and winning this game so this was
missiles idea and Petrosyan saw this
after the screen to a sex move Petrosyan
instead now he saw that rook captures
doesn't work
he played rook to c7 attacking the
bishop on c5 we have Queen to b6 now
attacking the rook defending the bishop
we have Bishop to f4 attacking the Queen
and defending the rook Queen moves to
the d5 and now we have rook to the 7
again attacking Smith lost Queen and
here's missile played simply Queen to b6
and here he forces the exchange of
Queen's
Queen captures we have rook captures and
now rook to c7 attacking the bishop
Bishop to b6 attacking the rook rook d7
and now c3 here's missile pushes c3 he's
creating a passed pawn we have B
captures B captures and now King to f1
allowing this Knight to move because
then the knight couldn't really move
rook to e1 was a threat now rook to the
8th comes
we had Knight to g5 attacking the rook
here there are a lot of interesting
moves for Smith's love rook to d1 being
the obvious option but Smith's table
again really takes his time I'm sure
he's enjoying this position immensely in
place the strongest rook to f6 allowing
allowing Petrosyan a one last idea
Petrosyan plays it Knight captures an f7
we had rook captures and now as the rook
is no longer protecting the bishop and
b6 now
Petrosyan captures it so he grabbed the
pawn now Petrosyan is up upon although
being down the exchange and again there
are a lot of interesting ideas here rook
to d1 always a very nice option but
Smith slope again goes for the strongest
move and he plays rook captures on f4
and it was in this position that former
world champion Tigran Petrosian resigned
at the game why did you resign well
first of all the bishop was guarding the
queening square so by removing the
bishop you have to capture the rook as
you're gonna be down a hole rook so G
captures on f4 and now c2 and there is
no way of stopping the pawn rook
captures on g6 but check King f7 rook to
c6 blocking but now what comes up to d1
check King e2 and c1 and the queen is
back in the game rook captures rook
captures and at the end of this very
nice variations miss Leveaux would be up
a hole rook with a completely winning
endgame so yeah I do hope you enjoyed I
do hope you enjoyed this game as its
it's not very long it's actually only 39
moves but what a you know what a
complicated game in the water sea of
variation variations miss love had
calculated before before actually
winning this game against Petrosyan but
you know after Pettersen played that g3
move it was so it was so I don't know so
educational and so refreshing to see how
house miss love punishes him
so yeah that's another game from the
1959 candidates tournament that I didn't
find any photos of Smith's Love Actually
playing against Petros and from this
tournament I don't know even probably in
those days
they didn't really didn't really
consider it important to take a lot of
photos you know there were photos there
were some photos of the players from
this tournament that were like in the
top three but not not from like every
round like like today so that's very sad
but that that is that is the case maybe
somewhere
there there you know photos exist but
you know I just don't have access to
them
but yeah like I said I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank James
Ross Don Dugan and David Compton for a
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
to really appreciate it and I don't
think I will be able to do another video
today as I am making preparations for my
stream it will start at 6:30 p.m.
Central European Time I do hope most of
you can make it and I wouldn't want any
of you to be discouraged from playing
since since all some grandmasters and
international masters applied for the
tournament as this is actually why I
gave out the the prize money so it would
attract some some stronger stronger
players and it would give you a chance
to play against them so while I'll be
streaming with an almighty we will you
know be enjoying some games and I will
be able to show live some of your games
when you will be playing against these
strong players so I do I do encourage
you to apply to the tournament and give
it your best you know it's gonna it's
gonna be a blast
so as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I hope most of you will be
able to make it today
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon